hier sortait sur netflix le documentaire
chambre 28,06 sur l' affaire dsk
un documentaire en quatre parties
réalisé par jalil lespert sur la fin du
sofitel qui avait secoué la planète
entière en 2011 comme un coup de
tonnerre et l'information choc dominique
strauss-kahn aurait été arrêté hier à
new york une affaire de moeurs et de
politiques comme les médias en raffolent
qui avait conduit à un accord secret en
2012 entre nafissatou diallo la victime
présumée et dominique strauss kahn
accusé de viol dsk qui avait dû renoncer
à se présenter à la campagne électorale
la même année laissant le champ libre
candidat socialiste françois hollande
nafissatou diallo qui a d'ailleurs
témoigné dans ce documentaire pour
donner sa version des faits et qui
semble encore aujourd'hui très troublée
par cette affaire c'est là il a mis son
chapeau push dsk de son côté a promis
qu'il s'exprimerait une bonne fois pour
toute dans un autre film documentaire
actuellement en préparation
une façon de revenir sur le devant de la
scène et de donner sa version des faits
car pour certains la sphère dsk est
encore et toujours un complot destiné à
faire tomber l'homme capable de
l'emporter en 2012 face à nicolas
sarkozy un homme puissant effet mis qui
dérangeait de nombreuses personnes
seraient potentiellement à l'adversaire
pour certains se trouvent que le
certains ans rappelle nicolas sarkozy à
l'époque pour d'autres la version
officielle selon laquelle dsk aurait bel
et bien agressé nafissatou diallo et la
bonne alors documentaire événement sur
dsk est il coupable alors je vous le dis
c'est un grand honneur pour nous d'avoir
yves derai éditeurs proche de dsk
rédacteur en chef chez forbes qui
connaît bien le dossier qui connaît bien
dsk merci d'être là yves merci je suis
très heureux de vous recevoir parce que
vous allez vous éclairer bien entendu et
c'est vrai que dans ce documentaire on
voit surtout on voit surtout nafissatou
qui voilà qui est très présente c'est la
version de nafissatou on a vu dominique
strauss kahn qui a dit il ya quelques
jours il s'est exprimé c'est sony
s'était jamais exprimée depuis très
longtemps qu a dit je vais faire mais
aussi un documentaire sur ma version des
faits il va participer à son
documentaire sur chacun à son
documentaire c'est sa porte pour dire
leur vérité leur vérité mais ce
documentaire que j'ai vu quand même
il ya aussi des gens qui défendent une
certaine manière dominique strauss kahn
donc il est assez équilibré quand même
vous vous vous arrêtez et au courant de
la faire très vite
vous avez vous la version de dominique
strauss kahn
nathan ce documentaire août leur côté
politique pour bien comprendre le
personnage
il ya des scènes où il monte dans le
documentaire le côté charmeur de
dominique strauss kahn
c'est vrai que dans les milieux voilà
qui conte oriental et dominique strauss
kahn
je sais qu isabelle tout le monde disait
voilà c'est un charmeur c'est un
dragueur ça c'est un truc qu'on
entendait beaucoup tourné énormément
énormément il a été un séducteur pendant
à partir du moment où il a rompu avec
son premier mariage avec hélène dumas il
est devenu un séducteur ya une femme sa
deuxième femme qui était un communicant
de brigitte guillemette qui l'a rabhi
est en fait raser la barbe etc et hop il
est devenu il plaît aux phares les boys
ont fait aux femmes il a beaucoup plu
aux femmes
mais cette histoire quand même et
l'histoire d'un séducteur déchu alors
que en fin de parcours il plaisait moins
aux femmes et donc qu'ils avaient
recours à d'autres manières pour n'était
pas son but reste la visionner terre
international au moment de la faire mine
de rien il avait donc c'est un poste
très très très important c'est un poste
très convoité
c'est vrai qu'on parlait lui ici aussi
en france est-elle favori pour devenir
le nouveau président à 69 à ce moment
est-ce qu'il n'était pas à l'apogée de
son succès avec les femmes aussi
donc là il n'est plus à l'apogée de
vacances à partir du moment où il ya
cette liaison avec piroska nagy au fmi
et rendu public qui est venu propose des
gros problèmes aux familles la séduction
avec les femmes devient très compliqué
anne sinclair d'abord maintenant ce qui
était sa femme à l'époque elle avait une
sorte de contrat avec lui un contrat
moral
elle savait qu'il avait une vie
tumultueuse mais pas d'histoire d'amour
avec piroska nagy
elle a su qu'il y avait des dîners aux
chandelles qui est des choses comme ça
donc là le contrat moral était rompue à
partir de là elle a beaucoup surveillez
et donc dominique strauss kahn ne
pouvait plus avoir cette vie de
séducteur de nos jugements qu'ils
avaient et puis qui de toute façon a
décliné parce que il prenait de l'âge
qui s'épaississent etc
on connaît tous ça n'est ce pas donc
voilà donc ça se passait
êtes vous encore donc voilà donc à
partir de là c'est vrai que c'est cette
vie de séducteur a décliné et qu'il a
commencé à il ya aussi la sphère du
carlton qui était organisée justement
pour qu'ils aient une vie sexuelle
qu'ils puissent s'amuser de ses parents
bien sûr qu'ils vont beaucoup ressortir
alors on va voir cette vidéo avec le
côté charmeur de dsk la préversion on a
plein de questions à vous poser c'est
parti ça car c'est parfaitement que next
risk and habitations d'être un séducteur
c'est aussi ce qu'elle aime en lui
d'ailleurs plusieurs de ses amis mettent
en garde anne sinclair l'une d'entre
elle rencontre un jour au restaurant
elle elle voit à quelques tables de la
dominique strauss kahn en train
d'embrasser une femme qui n'est pas un
saint clair mais anne sinclair à chaque
fois repoussées à l'air elle dit qu'au
fond ce sont les femmes qu'elles
provoquent
voilà bientôt à barra
[Musique]
je pense qu en cinq ans ne sait pas en
revanche l'ampleur des expériences si on
peut dire qu elle son mari alors
justement dsk était-il accro au sexe
comme tout le monde la firme regardais
les messages qu'ils envoyaient et on va
vous poser la question monsieur regardez
regardez ça il négocie avec les grands
de ce monde est temps qu'ils passent un
texto pour organiser ce sommet
ce qui est incroyable c'est qu'il il
prend même le risque de faire visiter
les familles ou aux femmes un qui
fréquente mais qui prennent en photo
dans son bureau
c'est insensé de de prendre de tels
risques
c'est comme si il considérait qu'il
était intouchable cedr sms lui parle de
matériel pour parler de femmes avec ses
copains on peut attendre d'un personnage
public toute la morale que l'on veut et
si on n'est pas content on vote pas pour
lui mais ça n'en fait pas un délit pénal
c'est une autre question il dort et que
vous vous étiez aux courbes douces et
semestre s'était fait des ces soirées en
tout cas oui on est au fond j'étais au
courant vous savez il ya eu un papier
dans le nouvel observateur en jour qui a
un peu raconté ces soirées sans citer
son nom mais dans le milieu politique et
les milieux journalistiques on savait
que c'était strauss-kahn qui était visé
dans cet article donc le bruit courait
qu'il n'était pas très plus d'enquêtés
dans des soirées privées
c'est désormais di martino et sur les
libertines ou poussiéreux et je vous dis
on n'échange pas des monstres à des
changes montre autre chose
oui et on échange aussi avec des
téléphones on peut filmer les gens à
leur insu éventuellement et donc quand
on est un homme qui veut devenir
président de la république c'est quand
même très casse-gueule voulait devenir
président pas c'est une vraie question à
vous poser une station est ce qu il
voulait vraiment venir de venir passer
une vraie question sert que ses amis le
voulait parfois plus pour que lui-même
mais ça on a beaucoup poussé à y aller
il avait la dimension intellectuelle
il avait un moment donné la carrure la
gela tout semblait concourir à ce qu'il
devienne président mais ce qu'il voulait
lui-même sachant que quand on est
président on peut plus avoir cette vie
qu'il aime lui de mon resto de bonne
chère de soirée amusant de tout ça est
ce que vous ne pensez pas que étant
donné qu'il est devenu extrêmement
dangereux était donné ce tram en deux
jours il ya plein de gens qui crient au
complot
c'est ça qui m'a veut dire aussi qu'il
ya eu un complot parce qu'il était
devenu tellement dangereux et qu'on
était persuadé que c'était le prochain
président qui a eu un complot autour de
lui c'est la thèse aussi qu'on peut
entendre ici et là
moi j'ai du mal à penser qu'il ya eu un
complot tel que les choses se sont
déroulées en tout cas j'ai des
sentiments en revanche que à partir du
moment où ils avaient un pied dans la
tombe
on lui a mis les deux pieds à la tête
reste là je les gens n'attendaient que
ça en fait bah il ya un certain en tout
cas qui n'attendait que ça les faux pas
de dominique strauss kahn et quand c'est
arrivé ils sont dit on va le
vraisemblablement même si moi de ma mon
intime conviction c'est qu'il n'aurait
jamais été présent à haute pensée bas
regardez même sans ça bah oui parce que
je pense qu'il n'aurait pas passé la
primaire il aurait été battu par
françois hollande lors de la primaire
fait mes sondages commençaient dès crois
que les courbes commencé à se croiser
françois hollande correspondait beaucoup
plus aux aspirations du peuple de gauche
strauss kahn avec son style de vie avec
ses positions sociales libérales etc ne
plaisait pas au peuple de gauche
donc ils n'auraient pas passé la
première n'aura pas été président alors
il ya un extrait aussi incroyable c'est
dsk qui est surpris au bois de boulogne
avec deux travestis l'info pas remonter
directement à nicolas sarkozy à l'époque
regarder ça nicolas sarkozy sait qu'en
2006 la police a arrêté deux voitures au
bois de boulogne où manifestement
plusieurs personnes étaient en train de
se battre donc les policiers ont reconnu
dominique strauss kahn nicolas sarkozy
c'est tout ce temps pour lui c'est une
évidence
dominique strauss kahn ne pourra jamais
aller jusqu'au bout à cause justement de
ces affaires avec les femmes lors d'une
conférence internationale
il ya un échange assez vif entre
dominique strauss kahn et nicolas
sarkozy ou de microscan dit en direct à
sarkozy je sais que tes gars cherche à
monter donne c'est entre moi et il vaut
mieux pour toi que tu que tu arrêtes
parce que sinon ça ira loin
ça c'est fou ça quand même écouter
d'entourage de nicolas sarkozy lui-même
je ne sais pas mais dans son entourage
les gens estimé quand même que dominique
strauss kahn est un peu culotté devoir
se présenter à la présidentielle contre
nicolas sarkozy alors que c'est sarkozy
qui l'avait quasiment fait nommer au fmi
il avait donné des avions présidentiels
il y avait soutenu dans sa campagne
donc il avait tout fait pour que strauss
kahn devienne directeur général du fmi
donc il trouvait que c'était une
trahison que strauss kahn tout d'un coup
c'est mon cible de sarkozy et 10 mg
achevée du piquet de poste et donc ils
avaient constitué ce qu'on appelle un
dossier il avait constitué un dossier
dans lequel y avait effectivement cette
affaire du bois de boulogne
petit le dossier tristane banon qui est
ailleurs justement pour aller ça joue et
qu'on voit cet article parce qu'il ya
donc documentaire nad69 sortie narsingh
incroyable de tristane banon qui évoqué
le cas de dsk dans l'émission de thierry
ardisson 93 faubourg saint-honoré et à
l'époque tout le monde
on rigolait regarde il a mieux je tienne
la main pour répondre parce qu'il m'a
dit je n'y arriverai pas si vous ne
tenez pas la main
il a dégrafé mon soutien-gorge et quand
je dis j'adore ces j'adore parce que ça
les jeux sans cesser ses sulfureux ça va
me faire du buzz
j'adore mais voilà quand je dis pas
j'adore le vieux ça s'est fini très très
violemment quand on se battait j'avais
parlé du lui avais dit le mot viol pour
lui faire peur ça ne lui a pas tort
puisque sa fin
on diffuse l'émission le samedi suivant
on a prévenu la chaîne combi p le nom de
dominique strauss kahn ont dû très
classes préprofessionnelles voilà donc à
rien c'est incroyable ça aussi parce que
ça derrière c'est vrai que tout le monde
en parle et ça c'est un truc qui est
jamais vraiment ça circulait pas mal ils
ont beebip et à chaque fois les choses
mais tristane banon - elle m'en a parlé
je rencontre un jour elle m'a raconté
cette histoire à peu près la même chose
que ce qu'elle racontait dans cette
émission
ce qui est étrange avec tristane banon
c'est que par la suite elle a porté
plainte non pas pour agression sexuelle
ce qui semble s'être passé dans cet
appartement
mais pour viol au viol et à la donner
une interview à l'express où elle a dit
que 2000 strauss kahn pardon il prouve
l'expression mais lui avait mis la main
dans la culotte est due à veules avaient
pénétré pour qu'ils violent et en fait
c'était la seule manière pour que sa
plainte soit acceptée parce que
l'agression sexuelle c'est prescrit au
bout de six ans et que là on était à 9
ans après les faits alors que violent
ses 20 ans donc c'est embêtant et donc
ce documentaire que j'ai vu mon en
entier parce qu'ils essaient en quatre
épisodes c'est assez loin ça dure près
de quatre heures mais j'ai tout regardé
et bien triste m.ban on parle maintenant
d'une tentative de viol alors qu'elle a
parlé de viol donc il ya un petit
problème comme avec tristane banon
alors la grosse exclue tant ce doc c'est
le premier témoignage fleuve et en vidéo
de nafissatou diallo
à l'époque des faits elle a 32 ans a les
femmes de chambre au sofitel de new york
regardez son témoignage elle allait
encore très marqué par cet épisode 9 ans
après quand elle en parle
mais bolt j'allais dire de ménage un
homme tout nu est apparu je lui dis oh
mon dieu je suis désolé monsieur je suis
désolé mais tout de suite il a posé les
mains sur ma poitrine gras il m'a
attrapé les seins et m'a dit ne soyez
pas désolé vous ne soyez pas désolé
époux l'a forcé à m'agenouiller vous ne
me reverrez il m'a repoussé vers le sol
j'ai dit arrêtez monsieur je ne veux pas
perdre mon travail
et là il a mis ce il lâche un peu ma
bouche
alors elle est encore bien sûr en
restait normale très marqué neuf ans
après ils devraient ça c est ce que vous
vous avez eue face à face là la version
de dominique strauss-kahn ce qui me l'a
raconté lui vont lui avoue ses droits sa
version après les événements je suis un
jour aller chez lui dans son appartement
de la place des vosges il était encore à
4 5 rire à l'époque d'ailleurs anne
sinclair est passé et puis elle est
partie et les yeux dans les yeux j'ai
voulu savoir parce que bien sûr on avait
publié de new delhi fram qui nous
engageait pas mal un grand éditeur il
faudrait donc c'est normal a donc j'ai
les yeux dans les yeux je lui ai posé la
question et il m'a dit il je vous assure
je ne peux pas vous jurés parce que je
ne jure pas je suis pas croyant mais je
vous assure que je n'ai pas violer
nafissatou diallo je peux pas vous en
dire plus et vous le croyez et donc je
le crois je le crois et je crois aussi
ce que raconte pas fils à toulouse
diallo je crois les deux parce que les
deux versions
à mon sens ne sont pas incompatibles
tout ce qu'elle raconte est assez
compatissait avec qui venait de là votre
version alors que moment en mêlant les
deux normes et non les deux et en
recoupant avec d'autres informations que
j'ai pu avoir aussi c'est que en fait
dominique strauss kahn a comme une forme
d'abus de position dominante
c'est à dire que cette femme elle rentre
dans cette chambre elle le voit nue elle
est là et lui mais elle sait que c'est
le directeur général du fmi parce
qu'elle est petite fiche en bas elle
sait exactement qu'il dans la suite
présidentielle c'est le personnage le
plus puissant d'hôtel un homme très
important elle sait pas encore qu'il est
français mais qui peut être président
république en france mais c'est que
c'est un homme très puissant et quand il
fait ce geste elle est tétanisée
elle n'est d'ailleurs quand elle dit que
il prend les seins elle aurait pu se
sauver elle aurait pu lui la porte est
ouverte elle peut sans navette et s en
va pas elle est tétanisée
elle est paralysée et elle s'exécute à
ses ordres en fait parce que des
tétanisés par l'indian position de
certaines donc c'est finalement sur le
plan disons juridique en droit
je ne crois pas que ça existe ce type de
viol
ce n'est pas condamnable en tant que
violent mais au fond 5n en tout cas elle
l'a vécu comme un viol et après
d'ailleurs je pense que elle reste c'est
assez étrange
elle ne va pas quand elle quitte la
chambre tout de suite voir l'infirmerie
elle va pas voir un chef et loire
maîtresse dans le couloir elle et elle
attend dans le couloir et lui sort
tranquillement calmement et sa petite
valise et lucie coucou il par ella ella
elle et vous versez parce que je pense
qu'elle attend peut-être une explication
quelques mots quelque chose en tout cas
de strauss kahn qui ne vient pas parce
que strauss kahn c'est un homme qui a
des défauts des qualités ses qualités c
qui comprend le monde
nulle personne est très intelligent mais
il comprend pas les gens il s'intéresse
pas aux gens il s'est pas intéressée à
cette femme du tout pas une seconde il
s'est pas dit que l avez vécu quelque
chose d'extrêmement traumatisant et
quand il a vu à 6 dans ce couloir il n'a
pas été vers elle pour lui dire quelques
mots peut-être pour alors échanger ou
dit qu'elle est là elle a réalisé dit
qu'elle savait c'était une personne très
importante mais dans le documentaire
alliés contraire elle dit qu'elle
découvre seul une fois rentrée chez elle
et que l'homme qu'elle accuse est une
personnalité connue dans le monde entier
et elle prend peur est la peur d'être
tués regardez il disait qu'il devait
être le prochain président français avec
des neiges ne savais même pas qu'il
était français et pose à et pour moi
c'était un blanc qui était d'ici au
mondial
j'ai entendu ça j'ai crié et j'ai pleuré
je me suis dit que j'allais mourir les
gens puissants sont capables de tout je
me suis dit qu'il allait envoyer des
gens vêtus et moi et ma fille
c'est ce que je me suis dit
alors voyez dockers elle nous dit
qu'elle savait pas et ne savait pas
qu'il allait être qu'ils étaient
français qu'il allait être président est
hétéro mais elle savait parce qu'il ya
des dents dans les vestiaires des gens
qui travaillent à l'hôtel ils ont pour
les personnalités importantes des
petites fiches descriptives et là elle
savait en plus d'incarner l'homme de la
suite présidentielle et nommé important
non mais vous vous donne donc l'île de
ré mais votre votre votre version c'est
que a votre avis il n'a pas comme il
voulu a dit je ne vais pas violer vos
amis voilà c'est ça donc oui pour lui
contraintes physiquement via les sapins
seront 30 physiquement mais elles
étaient tétanisés parce que il à y
laisser un abus de voilà de position
dominante mais oui mais je pense que
c'est extrêmement puissants comme
recevront quand on est une femme de
chambre dans un hôtel et qu'on est face
à un homme puissant qui aidera gilchrist
il pensait qu' il pouvait séduire toutes
les femmes c'est ça ici je pense qu'en
tout cas il a eu beaucoup d'expérience
avec beaucoup de femmes
oui parce que c'est vrai que quand il
était enseignant à la faculté il avait
paraît-il on l'a beaucoup raconté des
étudiants qui venaient le voir après le
court pour lui demander s'ils pouvaient
être le directeur de mémoire s'il
pouvait continuer à travailler après les
cours à l'assemblée on lui passaient des
petits mots c'est un homme qui avait une
forte attraction en 5 heures il l'a
séduite
qui est donc la seule femme qui est une
très belle femme et à l'époque où il a
séduit talent était extrêmement belle
elle est aidée et une grande qualité car
et grands dans le valais elle était
mariée avec israël
il était marié à brigitte guillemette
c'était des missions qu est ce que c est
le fauteuil se retourne et ya en chaque
entre quoi là car sa beauté son sourire
s'il ya quelque chose qui se passe entre
eux et ensuite ils ont eu une liaison
d'abord caché et puis ensuite ils ont
rompu chacun de leur côté pour se marier
et elle serait ce qu'en corps avec les
sief pas eu cette histoire son ex à bac
5 et ça je peux pas répondre à des
questions mais en tout cas c'est sûr que
ça fait beaucoup beaucoup de mal à leur
couple c'est quelque chose je crois
savoir que le livre en tout cas qui a
fait beaucoup de malades sinclair c'est
le livre de raphaëlle bacqué qui est
dans ce film qu'elle a écrit avec ariane
chemin et dans lequel en fait on met
bout
à bout toutes les histoires de sexe de
strauss kahn lors qu elles y sont toutes
le carlton
pas du tout ce canal j tout est mis
bout-à-bout et tout d'un coup quand on
lit ce livre on dit en fait ce type est
un monstre c'est un homme c'est un
malade sexuel
vous pensez que son ex-femme laluque
voilà et voilà quand elle a lu penser
que dominique strauss kahn peut revenir
sur la scène le devant de la scène
politique pour les élections 2022 ou pas
du tout et il n'est pas du tout je pense
que d'abord il pourrait pas faire en pas
dans une campagne sans avoir une armée
de deux militants qui viendraient
l'insulté et le trait et tous les noms
je pense que maintenant son image est
associée à l'addiction au sexe de
manière délirante et que extrêmement
forte et qu' avec les événements qu'on a
vécu l'enfer weinstein cetera
c'est plus du tout possible de voir un
dirigeant et puis c'est vrai que aussi
un homme aussi addict au sexe on se dit
que tient comme président république et
ce qui serait pas prisonnier de cela s
qui seraient pas capables de faire de
dire des choses qui est qu un président
de ne doit pas dire